On Prime Crime...
(screams)
WOMAN: Move! Move!
MAN: What the hell?
JESSE:
An annual holiday tradition
becomes a day of terror.
WOMAN: Oh, my God!
JESSE: But the drama
and twists of the case...
JESSE: ...don't end
in the interrogation room.
WOMAN 2: I need to take a break.
This man right now
is having a stare down with me.
It's very disrespectful.
He pounded his fist.
Frankly, it makes me scared.
Hi there, everybody.
I'm Jesse Weber
and welcome to Prime Crime.
This is where we break down
the most high profile
and memorable true crime cases.
What starts out
with a horrible crime
that destroyed the lives
of so many people
turns into a trial
that is still hard to believe.
(parade music)
JESSE: November 21st,
2021, Waukesha, Wisconsin.
Crowds gathered
along Main Street
for the town's
annual Christmas parade.
Two of my children
have been extremely involved
in the dance team.
They have danced
in the parade
for quite some time.
It was always
a really happy, fun event.
JESSE: Which should have
been a festive time with family
and loved ones, suddenly becomes
a nightmare caught on camera.
(screams)
WOMAN 3: Oh, my God!
I remember hearing stuff like,
I don't really know,
some commotion behind me.
(parade music) (screams)
MAN 2: Oh, my God! Oh, my God!
It was one of those
where I can still feel
the wind from
his vehicle as he passed me.
JESSE: A red Ford SUV
unexpectedly comes
barreling down the parade route,
striking multiple people.
Oh, my God!
This is a Christmas parade
that happened,
I think it's almost 60 years
that it's been going on.
And then suddenly
we have an individual that--
And just...
destroying every memory
anyone's ever gonna
have of that event.
(screams)
WOMAN 5: What the (beep)!
Oh, my God!
Oh, my God! Oh, my God.
Nothing like this
has ever happened
to this extent
in Waukesha County.
You can't believe
it's your own community,
you can't believe it's
your own friends and family.
(screams) (gunshots)
JESSE: Police are
quickly alerted
and begin to respond
to the chaotic scene.
JESSE: In total,
six people are killed,
dozens injured, and hundreds
of lives changed forever.
I followed the vehicle and
I saw everything that happened,
I kind of stood there
in shock for a little bit.
And then from there on,
it kind of hit me like,
I need to go find my daughter.
When I found her,
she was in front of the vehicle.
Once we got
to the fourth floor ICU,
it was there that they told me
that they had to intubate her
because of the seriousness
of her injuries.
WOMAN 6: Oh, my God! Oh!
JESSE: Authorities
immediately try to figure out
who did this, but the driver
of the red SUV disappears.
However, shortly after,
he's captured on camera
running through yards
in the surrounding neighborhood.
So what do we think
we-- that he's doing?
We think he's fleeing the scene.
JESSE: But as you'll see,
the unidentified man
then shows up on a ring doorbell
camera at a nearby house.
Hey, can I-- I called
some-- I called an Uber
and I'm supposed to be
waiting for it over here,
but I don't know
when it's coming.
Can you call it for me, please?
- I'm homeless.
JESSE: Police eventually
track the man down.
POLICEMAN 2: Hands up!
Hands where I can see them.
POLICEMAN 3: Hands up!
- Whoa, whoa, whoa!
POLICEMAN 4: Hands up, hands up!
BROOKS: Wait!
POLICEMAN 4: Get on the ground!
JESSE: Is Darrell Brooks
though, the driver?
JESSE: After he's detained,
authorities begin
to question him,
including the FBI.
You know that he-- during
his adult life, moved around
to several different states
and had collected
criminal histories in all
of those places along the way.
They're not obligated to tell
a suspect everything.
them the truth about everything.
JESSE: This is just the start
of Brooks's interrogation.
When we return,
things get very tense.
It's sad that an event
that is supposed to be
happy and joyous
just turned into something
so horrific
in a matter of just minutes.
(screams)
JESSE: In November,
2021, tragedy strikes
the small town of Waukesha,
Wisconsin, when a rogue SUV
barrels down the route
of an annual Christmas parade,
leaving six dead
and dozens injured.
JESSE: While police located
the abandoned red Ford SUV,
they eventually apprehend
the suspected driver.
Darrel Brooks Cameras
captured him going
from yard to yard
and even trying to seek refuge
at a stranger's home while
his behavior is suspicious.
Is he the killer?
They weren't
fully honest with him.
They didn't tell him exactly
what the investigation was.
In fact,
they told him this was more
about the domestic
violence incident.
Investigators start by asking
Brooks about an incident
with his on again,
off again,
girlfriend Erica Patterson.
An incident
that occurred right before
he allegedly drove
the car into the parade.
Why Erica was here in Waukesha
in the first place?
It was an attempt to get
away from Mr. Brooks after
he had run her over
with that same SUV
in Milwaukee just
a few weeks earlier.
To harass her
the way that he did,
to force her into the vehicle,
to punch her in the face,
a picture of Erica Patterson
and that black eye,
just shows just a fraction
of what she's been through.
JESSE: Although Brooks
denies attacking Patterson,
detectives press and search
for a possible connection
between the altercation
and the parade attack.
- There's no question
he's enraged,
and we see it in the video
when he's
with his ex-girlfriend.
JESSE: And then
investigators question Brooks
further
on details of his account.
In the whole...
story that he concocted
about getting a ride out here
from a friend, that was
all just intended to mislead.
I think what was interesting is,
they were both playing
mind games with each other.
He knew this was not about
a domestic violence incident,
and neither of them
are completely truthful
with each other.
They were persistent,
they were fair.
And at the very end,
they confronted him
with video
and photographic evidence.
JESSE: Brooks would
end up being charged
with 76 criminal counts,
including 6 counts
of first degree
intentional homicide.
But this is just the beginning.
The trial of Darrel Brooks Jr.
is something
no one will soon forget.
- Furthermore...
BROOKS: Not just today.
- I'm not done.
BROOKS: Cause that's a lie.
JUDGE DARROW: Let him finish.
BROOKS: Cause if he...
BROOKS: If we don't open
the door on that-- No,
since he wanna make a record
and not be accurate, so let's
be accurate all on the record
since you think
you know so much.
JESSE: Almost a year
after a red SUV barreled down
a parade route
in Waukesha, Wisconsin,
killing six people
and injuring dozens of others,
the alleged driver
of that vehicle is on trial.
Darrell Brooks Jr.
faced 76 criminal counts,
including
intentional homicide charges.
This was an accident
and he mistakenly wandered
onto the parade route.
After passing all this,
all he had to do was stop.
They could have
paused the parade.
He didn't.
It was intentional.
JESSE: This trial though,
was anything but conventional.
Do you wish to represent
yourself in this case?
BROOKS: Yes, I do.
There are times
when an individual
chooses to represent himself
and it ignores to his benefit.
There are times when
jurors can actually feel
sorry for the defendant.
This incident was not planned,
this incident
was not intentional.
A lot of suffering
involved in this incident.
A lot, a lot
of misunderstanding.
This trial was unlike
any other trial any of us
have ever been involved in
because
of his self representation.
BROOKS: I would
like to represent myself,
to represent myself
as a sovereign citizen.
Throughout the trial,
Darrell Brooks would bring up
many things
that were irrelevant.
One of them was
that he was a sovereign citizen.
It basically
was that he's not a citizen
of the United States,
and therefore the government,
the judge, the law doesn't
have any control over him.
We all kind
of figured he was gonna go
the sovereign
citizen direction there.
It was just one
of those where we're going,
"oh, great, here we go.
It's gonna be a rodeo."
Are we gonna address
subject matter jurisdiction?
JUDGE DARROW: The written
decision that I previously
entered is what I will stand on.
I don't think
he actually really believes
that he's a sovereign citizen.
I don't think
he believed that there was
an issue of subject
matter jurisdiction.
I think he's smarter than that.
His motive was just
to be a disturbance.
BROOKS: Objection.
Leading the witness. So to be...
JUDGE DARROW: It's overruled.
Now you may answer the question.
BROOKS: Grounds
for the overrule, your Honor.
JUDGE DARROW: It's overruled.
You may answer.
BROOKS: Grounds
for the overrule, your Honor.
It was, distracting
with all of his interruptions
and ramblings.
Would you describe them all
as being about teenage years?
BROOKS: Objection.
JUDGE DARROW: Overruled.
He may answer.
BROOKS: He's at the grounds,
your Honor.
Do you even know
the State of Wisconsin?
FEMALE ATTORNEY: Objection.
BROOKS: Grounds. Grounds.
JUDGE DARROW: Sustained.
- He would,
on the flip of a switch without,
without notice,
just go off on irrelevant topics
and not let it go.
The defense would like
to call the plaintiff's
state of Wisconsin to stand.
I object.
JUDGE DARROW:
The objection is noted.
It is sustained.
Call your next witness, please.
BROOKS: Reasons for the sustain?
JUDGE DARROW: Not relevant.
I believe the jury
deserves to know
who the plaintiff
is in this manner.
You don't know
who the plaintiff is.
JUDGE DARROW: Mr. Brooks,
please move on.
JESSE: But Brooks's outbursts
would become even more volatile.
I'm a grown man with grown kids.
Ain't nobody gonna talk
to me like that. Nobody.
He reminded me
of a two year old.
Every time something
started to go not his way,
he would throw a temper tantrum.
Literally.
JUDGE DARROW: This court
ordered Mr. Brooks be removed
from the courtroom due
to repeated interruptions.
He took his shirt off as well.
I'm also told
that he is threatening
to throw and break items.
JESSE: And Judge Jennifer
Darrow would find herself
on the receiving end
of much of Brooks's blowups.
I don't care,
which you believed fully.
- Alright.
- It's not a game.
The amount of lashing out
and disrespects...
was beyond belief.
JUDGE DARROW: Mr. Brooks.
- Whoa, ma'am, stop.
- Stop it.
- You aren't even letting me
- ask the questions.
BROOKS: You're a public servant.
(claps) I respect
your courtroom.
I respect you.
You're a public servant, though.
(claps) Your job
is to be the referee.
You know, I didn't think that
he would be that disrespectful.
He has no respect
for humankind at all.
FEMALE ATTORNEY:
I would like to provide
the defendant
and the court with a passage...
BROOKS: So that had to be,
that had to be said,
so it's (mocking voice)
"the defendant."
JUDGE DARROW:
That's not how it was said.
BROOKS:
That was how it was said.
You wanna run a record back?
FEMALE ATTORNEY:
I need to take a break.
This man right now is
having a stare down with me.
It's very disrespectful,
he pounded his fist.
Frankly, it makes me scared.
But she has to listen
to that and respond to it.
So her temperament was--
She deserves
high praise for that.
JESSE: Coming up, we break
down the legal arguments
for each side.
And before the final decision,
the families
don't hold anything back.
I can only hope
they lock you away someplace
so deep the rats
chew on your fingers at night.
JUDGE DARROW: Mr. Brooks's
statement that the audio
doesn't work when I mute
him is simply false.
BROOKS: I can't say nothing
about the audio not working,
so you need to stop
lying on the record!
JESSE: In 2022,
a jury in Waukesha, Wisconsin,
is listening to the trial
of Darrel Brooks, Jr.,
the man accused
of driving an SUV
through a holiday parade
the year prior.
A trial where
the defendant decided
to represent himself
in wild fashion.
JUDGE DARROW: You are
not being respectful
to this proceeding
or to this jury.
- With all respect...
JUDGE DARROW: No, it's not
with all due respect,
stating that
- doesn't make it respectful.
- I was giving you...
JESSE: Brooks faced
76 criminal charges
for allegedly killing 6 people
and injuring dozens of others.
We wanted do right by these
victims and by our communities.
These families
all suffered so greatly
that we absolutely
wanted to do our best.
I watched the body
fly up onto the hood
and her head snapped back,
and the body
remained on the hood
as it passed
the side of my vehicle.
Asking these witnesses
to relive these events
was very difficult for us.
FEMALE ATTORNEY: Did
you see the red SUV
strike any people in
the Catholic community group?
Several.
It was in the air,
like bowling pins.
Some of the witnesses had
indicated that they even noticed
that he almost had
this look on his face,
like he knew exactly
what he was doing,
exactly where he was going.
I saw a man
focused on the group
ahead of him.
FEMALE ATTORNEY: Is that Darrell
Brooks that you saw?
- Yes.
JESSE: While the prosecution
would present evidence
tying Brooks to the crimes,
Brooks presented
another side of the story.
Well, what were
the defenses to his case?
First was that there was
a mechanical error with the car.
We believe that there may have
been some mechanical problems.
How were you able
to come to that determination?
That was my initial concern
because of the noise
that the engine was making.
The second issue was
that they didn't
have the right guy.
Could you see
anybody inside the vehicle?
Your answer was, "I could not
see the person real clearly."
And then the last
one he brought was,
the person who did this
did not intend
to kill the individuals
because they honked beforehand.
So you heard a horn beeping?
Yes.
BROOKS: Was it coming from
the vehicle
that you tried to stop?
I believe that it was.
JESSE: And at one point,
Brooks appeals
to the jury's emotions,
and even improperly argued
that the jury
could ignore the law.
You have the power
to nullify any law
that you don't agree with.
FEMALE ATTORNEY: Objection.
Move to strike misstatement.
JUDGE DARROW: Sustained.
JESSE: In late October, 2022,
a 12 person jury reached
a unanimous verdict
after about
three hours of deliberations.
"We the jury find the defendant,
Darrell E. Brooks,
guilty of first
degree intentional homicide."
JUDGE DARROW: Hey.
You are to be removed right now.
JESSE: The jury found
Darrel Brooks Jr.
guilty of all
76 criminal charges.
We had witnesses
that identified him,
we had video
that identified him.
The fact that he was close by,
the lies he told.
He darn well knew
exactly what he had done.
JESSE: Nearly a year
to the day following the attack,
at the sentencing hearing,
Brooks faced
the victim's families
and the survivors
of the parade Attack massacre.
And there's, there's
nothing this court can do
that would provide
justice in my eyes.
So all I ask is
that you rot and you rot slow.
Times where I felt
justice wouldn't be served
until he had to take
that SUV to his chest
exactly the same way
he treated my child.
And I hope the look
on my daughter's face
before you ran her over haunts
you for the rest of your life.
That whole experience
really opens up your eyes
to know how fast things can
be ripped away from you
and can change your life
in a matter of seconds.
Jocelyn is doing amazing,
it's surprising how well
she has bounced back.
The recovery process
has been a very long journey.
Very long and exhausting.
It was a lot of physical therapy
and doctor's appointments.
I'm doing pretty good.
JESSE: As for Brooks,
he had some words
before his official sentencing.
Not only am I sorry
for what happened...
I'm sorry
that you could not see...
what's truly in my heart.
JESSE: But Judge Darrow
wasn't convinced.
Frankly, Mr. Brooks,
no one is safe from you.
This community can only be
safe if you are behind bars
for the rest of your life.
This court is
imposing a life sentence
without the possibility
or eligibility
for extended supervision
consecutive to one another.
(audience claps)
And our thoughts just stay with
our community and our families.
They still need a lot of love,
a lot of support
and a lot of prayers.
Closure is a word that gets used
a lot in this business,
but I hope at least
they can rest knowing
that Darrell Brooks is
sleeping in prison every night.
It's really not
an understatement to say
just how absolutely devastating
this case has been for so many.
And yes, a lot of attention
focused upon Darrell Brooks
and his wild behavior
during trial,
but we shouldn't forget what
this case has always been about,
and that is the victims.
Because despite all
of Brooks's arguments,
this jury seemingly
didn't believe anything
he had to say,
and they delivered a verdict
that holds him fully
accountable for what he did.
That's all we have for you
here on
Prime Crime.
As always,
thank you for joining us
and until next time, stay safe.